oui le menu fait déjà mal à la tête j'ai
tout excuser au chaud ce retour sur
l'hexagone
un jeu flash alors c'est un jeu qu'on
m'a envoyé j'ai pu tester très très vite
fait auparavant mais j'ai bien
évidemment très rapidement quitter
vous avez de comprendre pourquoi alors
je contrôle la petite flèche il faut que
je passe dans dans tous les trous du
triangle
ouah je suis jamais allé jusque là c'est
juste pas possible et on a une musique
incroyable avec des effets de lumière
qui vont très très mal à la tête
oui le malin voilà c'est ça donc tu
passes au niveau 2 puis tu meurs
obligatoirement à la la non mais là je
suis naze je pense à tous le cerveau
parce que mon cerveau va exploser vous
avez vu juste la vitesse à laquelle ça
se met à les buteurs on a 100 sur
l'autoroute près cette année en plus la
flèche que tu l'a déplacé elle va vite
et cela est dû coûter au sahara mais je
vous assure
avais je ferais je fonce et j'appuie la
up up la pêche
elle bouge un truc de dingue le moment
j'ai voulu montrer ça ne bougeait pas
oui c'est ça mais c'est un beau signe à
dos qui s'est laissée comme les trucs
dans les petits mecs et tu continues tu
t'écartes verre sur la tête c'est comme
les attractions je disais dans les
petites fêtes foraines où le truc tourne
il est sur un truc qui tourne qui lui
même et sur un truc qui tourne et on
obtient des trucs de malade quoi allez
c'est bon là on tient quelque chose tu
en fais ton cerveau il acheté que
j'arrive à passer le quatrième trio a eu
3 4 5 6
voilà là j'arrive plus à suivre c'est
juste impossible le jeu le moins amusant
du monde ta ta ta ta ta ta joue toute la
journée puis tu peux te céder sa part
dans la forme totalement géométriques
aujourd'hui un cours de géométrie
qu'est ce qu'un triangle équilatéral ah
non mais attendez le truc c'est c'est
pire que les boks donne père marius je l
on tient un truc là oh lalala lalala
mais qu'est ce qu'on est supposé faire
mais [ __ ] mais bien mais il faut avoir
un pouvoir quoi comme ses rebonds pour
passer ce jeu juge arrivera un compromis
aaa est sûre s appuyer sur a zappé sur
une touche
il fallait à l'attenté celle-ci
olalalala complications c'est pourquoi
j'ai une pub pour ron éléphants ron plus
tard close
ok voilà un temps je perds ce parce
qu'il ya des pubs sur site un marrant
c'est le crescendo que tu peux avoir
quand tu te met à chanter tu commences
ce niveau tu fais ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta explosion de cerveau au mic
a voulu vous faire mal afin qu'un pays
nous avons ici l'épreuve du bac dans 20
ans
oh non mais mais juste même au ralenti
je n'y arriverai pas toi l'amour ralenti
des examens que décrit yogi place coup
le titre ibo
à et là tu boulette en a marre là je
vous assure
essayez le lien dans la description mais
mon but mais il faut aller tout à gauche
en moins d'une seconde le curseur va pas
assez vite
oui à deux minutes je disais qu'il
allait s il allait trop vite justement
mais bon respect des contrats des chiens
sales cons je sais même pas si vous
allez à comprendre le but du jeu a mais
[ __ ] j'ai trouvé un game over encore
pire que ragdoll olympique coi jamais
réussi [ __ ] c'est un peu bêtement d'un
fokker 100 km heure
olala cette chanson est là on la
remplace par une petite comptine pour
enfant a le jeu est tout de suite bien
bien ah là là c'est bien meilleur
peut-être pas en fait le mec qui a fait
ça aussi qu'on fait quoi y'en a qui tue
déjà un ado qui font des jeux comme
hexagone quoi je vais arriver à
sérieusement j'ai mal aux yeux
oh est ce que vous payez l'ophtalmo
après simple question 1 pour ceux qui
font des crises d'épilepsie eux s'ils
payer le
lalalalala du thé du dj la blague du dj
hexagone était avec nous soit vous me
faire plaindre hexagonal va tous nous
donnait mal ou comme balle à la tête il
varie entre le maire et le orange de
couleurs sont disponibles à l'achat du
jeu oooh
tu veux te suicider car tu en as marre
de la vie plutôt que de jeter sous les
rails d'un train joua hexagone que
nouveau jusqu'aux autorisé par la morgue
je fais tu as mais j'ai bien de
seulement de comprendre qu'il faut il
jouer en retirant son casque a à z par
contre ça fait pas gagner ça allait je
commence à avoir beaucoup fortement
balle à la tête
je comprends pas je coûts compass qui se
passe qu'on appelle à la puissance
de quelqu'un si tu m'entends aide moi à
réussir ce jeu
dieu est ce qu'on va oui oui allez tous
me tape dans ses mains pour cent du tout
le monde tape dans ses mains opt'in
j'imagine bien un mec qui a un stand à
une fête foraine où c'est le
l'attraction basse et ce jeu là les
danois noma venez vous faire exploser le
cerveau exploser le crâne explosion
garantit pas de frissons mais le crâne
allez allez allez allez squeeze joue en
hexagone 2e un bon ouais ouais je crois
ou fouet aux la pop a tant fait ouverte
en continu
ouah
question
je sais que ça peut choquer mais je
faisais cette question
c'est tout